so Mike how was the experience out there
in the in the village that was a great
parade a little bit dangerous
as you'll see there were there was some
some creatures about you know I saw your
dad was on 1010 wins this morning he was
reporting on I guess in one of the
boroughs people are running around
killing stray cats
that's the reporting sight sir that's
that sites are not strutting anymore of
course Travis knows so of course he
listens to it he's a well-known musician
shut up you guys
Travis loves the standing bass let's go
Strava such a [ __ ] music so more
[ __ ] Henry alright so let's see let's
see what you guys filed down there at
the at the village yeah pedda live here
in Washington Square Park where the
Halloween spirit is in the air you can
see a revelers and trick-or-treaters
making their way about oh my gosh wait a
minute hang on applause Mike Mike did
you just get attacked by werewolf I was
attacked by a by a werewolf and then you
became you see what happened Mike was
trying to file his report and a werewolf
because it's Halloween came and attacked
him at twink werewolf look like he
didn't look like rather werewolf was
just wearing a t-shirt and it was a
small wear yeah Park 264 on a back of
flavortown you know I have to tell you
something
listening if you keep there could be
something where people are in costume
all the time because the same thing with
comic-con listening to people in costume
try to stay in character that's the best
it's the greatest thing the boys are
awful they don't match no and they're
clearly like they're stumbling through
cuz they're trying to think of like the
character yeah but it's not working
favorite Halloween snack
Halloween snack oh it's always buffalo
wings man
always Buffalo for weeks if let me ask
something if you were a werewolf on the
prowl for a little [ __ ] where
flavortown
what uh what kind of seasoning would you
throw on there Thai chili Thai chili
chili won't that burn her labia minora
and majora
that's how you got to do it all right
is that a guy fairy phrase if it ain't
hot it's not right very good
poor guy Mike just keep throwing
questions at him yeah to try to get him
to break character he's really
struggling he is maybe there's a less
spicy sauce week ago with less spicy now
you're not living life you're not doing
it spicy right that afraid you're not
living life when it comes to the [ __ ]
yeah he says that yeah hey man you know
what I always say if you're not doing it
spicy you're not living life but mr.
Vladimir Putin on vitomir Putin oh we
got to that yet oh okay I'm sorry I
didn't mean to jump ahead of things so
what's this business going on this is my
moment you don't anymore mo oh I see
it's a fun question means wearing a
Vladimir Putin mask
and he's standing on Donald Trump's
shoulders like a Donald Trump no you
might don't think that's how the outfit
works
yes sure mhm are you with them we're
curious as to how he wound up down there
worked out in the West Village or down
there well down there in the West
Village is there something you guys
would like to tell us we were at a party
uptown things got weird Trump started
ordering tequila vibes
ladies and gentlemen there's only one
thing that sound could be that is the
sound stupid Vladimir Putin's for
stupidest fake letter in Putin's
forehead headfirst on the microphone
what great sound bounces off miss
peripherals nothing good
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
Sirius XM a/v